la vie politique en france c'était
quelque chose mais ça c'était avant un
monde disparaît il est submergé par des
réseaux sociaux engloutis par les
plateformes recouvert par des images
bientôt l'élection du président de la
république sera anecdotique les
visiteurs sont parmi nous ils ont gagné
hop
je suis la femme contre laquelle se
concentrent toutes les attaques dans
marche depuis janvier toutes les
attaques
ah ben alors là
[Applaudissements]
comme image
d'un abruti
c'est toi ça te dit tu n'es pas bien sûr
va perdre du poids
sur les projets c'est très intéressant
je veux bien
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
vous avez le droit de pas être d'accord
avec moi vous avez droit aussi de
m'écouter moi je vous respecte donc je
viens vous parler
[Musique]
si je puis dire à quelqu'un
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle sur les
dalton enfin j'espère qu'ils vont
vraiment qu'ils vont tenir leurs
promesses hymne au jury qu'il ne ferait
plus aucune mes actions voilà ils m'ont
dit tout à l'heure nous dit on on fera
plus a dit devriez devenir curé au bas
écouter bail déjà
à préchauffer brême
adjugé 1 la dame et vous verrez la
moitié des sondés estiment que oui c'est
toujours à l'homme de faire le premier
pas est le premier baiser pour plus de 4
français sur 10 l'homme doit gagner plus
d'argent que sa femme au sein d'un
couple c'est donc cet écart 1 qui porte
le nom de romance gap qu'on peut
traduire par fausser amoureux pourtant
dans le même sondage 85% des français
interrogés estiment que l'égalité de
genre est très importante dans un couple
vous faites c'est le dilemme permanent
on veut plus d'égalité mais on reste
attaché quand même certaines autres à
dijon une femme premier ministre vous et
pensez vous avez des nous a donné ce
soir bien sûr envie d'y penser ou pas
bien sûr j'y ai pensé j'y pense et la
fois jeu évidemment j'aurais si les
françaises et les français me font
confiance un gouvernement paritaire je
ferai tout pour avoir une force
majoritaire à l'assemblée paritaire ce
qui est quasiment le cas
les femmes sont considérées comme étant
plus fortes que les hommes
on peut dire que ce sont elles des big
thing
ce sont elles qui donnent la vie
qui souffrent à l'accouchement
à côté nous les hommes on n'a pas grand
chose à faire à part se détendre
ici au danemark ce sont des femmes qui
prennent les choses en main moi je
voudrais qu'il y ait même une
possibilité de délit de non partage des
tâches domestiques faire reconnaît dans
un couple on partage d'accord que les
femmes font quand même huit heures de
plus de travail par semaine
domestique un délit de non partage des
tâches domestiques m'a filmée ton
conjoint grèce dans le canapé pendant
que toi tu es dans la cuisine bah tu
l'envoies et on porte le prince année
encore plus forte plus le délit de non
partage de l'addition reste aussi
y aura une pension de reversions donné
leur traversée je crois qu'il aura noté
sur tender là sur son antenne là c'est
pas là je la bois depuis tout à l'heure
la caisse qui se passe là